[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission on
parle cuisine alimentation agriculture
écologique et un peu politique et cette
semaine un invité exceptionnel Olivier
rollinger bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et avec moi
pour présenter cette émission
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour Brigitte bonjour Olivier
rolandet bonjour vous êtes chef
cuisinier vous avez été auréolée de
trois étoiles distinction rares des
toquées pour votre restaurant Le
Bricourt à Cancale en Bretagne pourtant
rien ne vous prédestinait à vous mettre
au fourneau à part sans doute un appétit
forcené pour la vie après un accident
terrible qui voulait plusieurs semaines
dans le coma mais en 2008 coût de
théâtre vous déclarez forfait estimant
que vous n'avez plus la condition
nécessaire vous rendez donc vos étoiles
mais pas les armes une reconversion
professionnelle à seulement 53 ans alors
que la retraite était encore à l'époque
à 62 ans vous assouvissez alors une
passion le commerce des épices après
avoir construit votre renommée sur le
saint-pierre retour des Indes soulignant
le trait d'union entre Saint-Malo et
l'ancienne colonie britannique et pour
se déjeuner on met le pied à terre avec
des produits de saison oui
asperges blanches mousseline au cerfeuil
et on desserre une tarte à la rhubarbe
dans le dessous des plats le secret des
épices rollinger un mélange savamment
orchestré entre père et fille ils nous
ont ouvert leur laboratoire secret dans
les pieds dans le plat la viande de labo
qui débarque dans les boucheries et les
restaurants de Singapour avec du poulet
fabriqué avec des cellules souches
faut-il s'inquiéter ou se régaler
d'avance allez on passe à table tout de
suite cuisine et confidence
alors si je voulais vous taquiner
Olivier roland-gier je dirais que votre
passage à l'association Relais et
Châteaux en 2009 comme vice-président a
laissé chez vous des traces puisque vous
ne jurez plus que par cet asperge blanc
raffiné naguère adorait à la cour et
considéré comme un légume Royal non plus
sérieusement je dirais et n'y voyait
aucune ironie que vous lui ressemblez à
cet asperge et oui comme elle vous
préférez en dépit de votre CV long comme
un jour sans huître l'ombre à la lumière
la discrétion au buzz et comme elle vous
aimez aussi avoir les pieds dans le
sable vous le Breton plus attiré par la
côte que par la mer la preuve avec vos
maisons gourmandes sur la falaise de
Cancale et lorsqu'on évoque votre
passion pour les épices vous n'incarnez
pas forcément le navigateur intrépide
genre Magellan mais plutôt ce génial
compositeur n'est pas là capable de
créer ces mélanges inédits comme votre
poudre de Neptune savon mélange Danette
de fenouil de badiane d'algues et de
sésame qui sublime les aliments comme
cette asperge blanche
mais vous avez exigé une mousseline au
cerfeuil plus classique par modestie
pour ne pas vous mettre en avant avec
vos épices c'est à dire que je me
dépasse toujours avec mon poivre à la
mode de Paris donc
toujours mon plat oui non je voulais
apporter absolument ce mélange parce que
je vais créer justement après les
événements de les attentats à Paris je
voulais rendre hommage au goût au palais
des Parisiens des Parisiens et Associés
toutes les les poires qui ont été à la
mode du XVIIIe siècle aujourd'hui dans
une mignonnette et bien souvent
lorsqu'on est nomade parisien ou on
travaille tout le temps à l'extérieur et
on déjeune toujours à l'extérieur et
parfois bien souvent on a simplement une
espèce de poussière de poivre sur sa
table et d'intéressant et puis toujours
le moulin à poivre mais quel type de
poivre et là vous avez votre mignonnette
vous vous mettez votre petite
mignonnette de poivre et vous pouvez le
mettre dans la poche parce que moi
j'adore le poivre
beaucoup de gens se promènent avec
justement parce que je considérer que
c'était
oui il faut il faut
que j'adore non mais à la fois du poivre
et différentes mélanges qui ont fait qui
ont qui à un moment donné ont été
totalement prisés par par les Parisiens
et les Parisiens donc je trouve que
c'était rendre hommage un petit peu
comme comme chacun d'entre nous j'étais
évidemment bouleversé par ces par
c'était par ce moment tragique et j'ai
voulu penser c'est quoi le goût des
Parisiens des Parisiens à travers le
poivre comment ils assaisonnent leur
place et comment le rendre la vie facile
c'est Nomad de urbain et le poivre on en
met partout sur tous les plats je veux
dire que le poivre c'est pas
probablement une des seules épices que
l'on peut utiliser seul et que l'on peut
mettre quasiment partout voir même dans
des desserts alors vous êtes la seule
personne qui vient on vous parle des
asperges et vous nous parlez épices mais
non bah alors je parlais du asperges du
cerfeuil pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui
on l'a le plein le printemps explose
c'est c'est sur les bourgeons c'est la
vie c'est la vie qui sort de la terre
comme ça
l'asperge elle est très elle est très
symbolique elle est là c'est le vivant
qui apparaît et c'est presque magique où
les enfants ont leur aujourd'hui c'est
pour ça que je prône l'éducation du goût
à l'école comme on l'aura on leur
apprend à écrire à lire à compter on
devrait leur apprendre aussi à se
nourrir parce que quel merveille il y a
pas un jeu plus merveilleux que de
regarder d'observer la nature et ce
cycle du vivant et puis le cerfeuille
c'est le ces herbe plutôt divers mais
c'est juste la fin parce que dès qu'il
peut avoir les grosses chaleurs ça va
être fini donc c'est juste un moment de
transition et puis une mousseline parce
qu'il y a toujours un œuf et l'œuf c'est
le printemps c'est la vie c'est la vie
aussi
Olivier je suis désolé mais moi je les
asperges je les mange avec avec les
doigts voilà
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
je préfère les asperges blanches
des charnues leur
très joli longueur en bouche parce que
je les trouve plus glissé oui et avec
cette pointe d'amertume et j'aime
toujours l'amertume dans les plats je
pense que c'est la saveur intelligente
et
l'associé justement à cette douceur
cette rondeur de la moustine avec cette
saveur légèrement anisé de cerfeuil
elles sont délicieuses une petite
interrogation sur la mousseline vous la
faites comme ça
c'est une interprétation elle est très
bien elle est très bien alors
Jean-Pierre trois choses à savoir
olivier roland-gier est un collab sur
les asperges alors l'asperge blanche
fait partie de la même famille que les
vertes mais elle doit sapeur au fait
qu'elle pousse sous terre et qu'elle est
protégée de la lumière du jour par des
petites buts elle préfère les sols
légers et sablonneux donc on en voit en
Bretagne énormément dans la baie du
Mont-Saint-Michel alors avant de les
consommer ces asperges blanches il faut
bien les éplucher avec un couteau
économe en partant de la tête et puis en
allant jusqu'à la queue et en forçant un
peu parce que c'est à la base qu'elle
est plus dure et plus rêche et puis on
peut garder les épluchures c'est ce que
doit faire Olivier rollinger parce que
ça peut faire un petit bouillon et
parfumer quelque chose donc zéro déchet
enfin la cuisson des asperges c'est
plutôt 20 minutes dans l'eau mais on
peut aussi les faire cuire pour garder
plus de saveurs à la vapeur et même en
papillote dans un papier parchemin et
puis bah là c'est plus long les fécures
30 minutes au four et on peut les servir
à une Bruce line avec une sauce
hollandaise mais avec une simple
vinaigrette exactement ou même comme ça
avec un peu de poivre nature voilà
comment
moi j'ai cuit toujours à l'eau mais
dans très peu d'eau
légèrement salée et je réutilise un
petit peu de cette eau justement pour
monter ma mousseline ah oui c'est très
bon et
mais je vous écoute parler là vous êtes
un merveilleux de cuisine vous à la
maison excellent cuisinier du dimanche
j'aime le entendre parler donc avec
Brigitte on parle que de ça
c'était un plat que vous qu'on pouvait
trouver à la carte par exemple chez vous
oui alors effectivement je l'associais à
quelques épices comme ces points enfin
ces différents poivre mais c'est un plat
qu'on peut on pourrait retrouver en
particulier qu'on pourrait aujourd'hui
trouver dans le bistrot de Cancale que
on a ouvert sur la plage non c'est le
Bistrot de Cancale on a ouvert sur la
plage de Port mer alors que le
coquillage aujourd'hui c'est mon fils
qui qui mène la danse et qui a tenu à
l'âge de 30 ans
sa deuxième étoile et qui son père qui
était cuisinier de la nuit en 2022 donc
c'est un garçon qui qui écrit une
cuisine qui est totalement différente de
la mienne
et qui à la fois une cuisine à la fois
très engagée
une forme de radicalité mais bourré de
poésie et bourré de délicatesse j'en
parle violence quand on parle à la
cuisine de son fils mais évidemment il y
a ces choses-là mais en fait on raconte
la même histoire ce qu'on a pas les
mêmes crayons de couleur donc on fait
pas on a les mêmes crayons de couleur on
fait pas le même dessin c'est trois
choses et sortilège de la baie du
Mont-Saint-Michel les croyances de
l'arrière-pays celtique et le
marche-pied de l'aventure qui est
l'horizon et là évidemment ça en
utilisant les épices mais c'est d'abord
la mer la terre et lui il a ce goût
marin il a mis de côté non pas parce
qu'il est végétarien il a mis de côté il
a pas envie de travailler des viandes
puisqu'il considère qu'il a des poissons
il y a des coquillages il est crustacés
il a les algues il a les légumes vous la
définiriez comment moi c'était une
cuisine marine potagère un parfum
d'épices alors que lui c'est une cuisine
potagère vous on disait que vous êtes
bien inventé la cuisine métissée oui
alors oui oui je revendique tout à fait
parce que j'ai rappelé simplement
aux françaises et aux Français que
lorsqu'on lit une recette de cuisine
française le premier chapitre sont les
ingrédients un grand chapitre parce
qu'il y a une multitude d'ingrédients
c'est merveilleuse qu'on a on a dans un
pays de coquin quand même ensuite des
techniques absolument incroyables
deuxième chapitre technique comment
faire et puis le dernier le titre du
chapitre dernièrement assaisonnement sel
poivre une maigreur sans nom alors que
la nature nous a donné tellement de
choses dans le monde pour simplement
donner du goût au plat et évidemment et
en utilisant en faisant des mélanges et
moi
l'idée c'est de faire le mélange pour
non pas pour faire un gara masala ou un
colombo mais pour faire un mélange avec
un goût de Breton un goût de français et
et donc comment associer avec une asper
vous aimez particulièrement cuisiner
parce que c'est les produits de la mer
éviter
parce que justement dans les maisons de
Brico aujourd'hui c'est Hugo qui cuisine
avec toute son équipe une partie de mes
anciens d'ailleurs ils font ils font une
équipe absolument exceptionnelle et puis
à la maison j'ai la chance d'avoir une
femme qui cuisine beaucoup mieux que moi
non mais bien sûr mais bien sûr c'est
elle qui cuisine ah c'est un bel hommage
que vous les rendus
ou elle fait un autre métier à part ah
bah au départ ma femme elle est
pharmacien ensuite elle m'a accompagné
par amour dans toute cette aventure un
peu de cinglé et et aujourd'hui que
c'est une passion pour elle mais c'est
pas son métier c'est
bien souvent et enfin dans tous les cas
ma femme est dans ce sens et je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de maman il y a
beaucoup de de
c'est un acte d'amour cuisine
et que alors ça peut être un papa ça
peut être un grand-père aussi mais
elle a besoin de donner c'est pour elle
c'est une preuve d'amour au quotidien et
je suis très sensible alors un chef
étoilé au quotidien qu'est-ce que ça
qu'est-ce que ça mange est-ce que vous
êtes quand même toujours sur le produit
c'est brut ou c'est on a la chance nous
à Cancale d'avoir
un potager au-dessus de la mer
extraordinaire alors c'est le pot de la
Bretagne est un potager au dessus de la
mais enfin devrait être un merveilleux
potager bio au-dessus de la mer
malheureusement elle est un peu trop
souvent
non pas une zone d'élevage mais l'usine
à protéines animales ce qui n'a rien à
voir avec un élevage mais je veux dire
c'est et puis on a des coquillages des
crustacés des absolument extraordinaire
dans toutes ces bêtes Cancale dans cette
bête Saint-Malo les poissons on a des
poissons on a des alors on est en
particulier macro des soldes on est gâté
donc il suffit finalement d'aller sur un
marché d'avoir nos producteurs et en
plus nous on a la chance d'avoir un
champ grand champ ce qu'on appelle le
chant du vent qui plonge dans la mer et
on a 80 aujourd'hui
on est totalement autonome en légumes
quoi donc
c'est une cueillette des légumes servis
dans vos restaurants sont issus de ces
terres potagères c'est dingue qu'est-ce
qu'il y a les 15% qui reste nos
producteurs il s'agit pas non plus il y
a des choses et bien par exemple nous
Hugo fait énormément de de
utilise énormément d'herbe il utilise
par exemple même beaucoup de rhubarbe
vous avez vous avez des lignes de
rhubarbe comme ça qui plongent dans la
mer absolument exceptionnel vous avez
des en ce moment c'est les fèves on n'a
jamais les fèves au bon moment il y a
les feuilles quand on recueille la
veille ou le matin pour le jour même ça
n'a rien à voir avec une fève qui a
traîné il faut pas qu'elle soit il faut
pas l'emmener trop loin parce que là
elle devient un peu farineuse les petits
pois c'est pareil les haricots verts
c'est pareil la cueillette et quand les
les cuisinières et les cuisiniers
l'équipe va accueillir la notion de la
cueillette et dans suite de prendre des
Cossais mais
cette valeur de l'intention d'aller
jusqu'au bout et juste de la cuire à
peine l'assaisonner un soupçon
on donne un autre sens et c'est une joie
ça vous manque pas de plus être derrière
les fourneaux de plus avoir à toute
cette j'en rêve encore de cuisiner alors
j'imagine encore en particulier beaucoup
de mélanges d'épices alors même si
aujourd'hui c'est plus ma fille aussi
qui
elle s'investit énormément et qui a un
palais absolument incroyable
si je gamberge beaucoup encore des
saveurs en fait un plat les gens me
disent mais comment ça se passe mais
d'abord c'est du travail ça fait 40 ans
que je suis en train de goûter des
choses passe mon temps à goûter et être
curieux curieux du monde curieux de la
vie et
lorsque vous voulez mélanger comme ça il
y a une ligne c'est comme une ligne
éditoriale vous ça doit raconter une
partie de l'histoire de l'aventure
maritime et c'est comme ça que vous
construisiez vos recettes à l'époque
vous les écriviez oui
ça peut être à la fois trois jours donc
ça peut être deux ans c'est un petit peu
comme un comme un frère j'ai un grand
ami qui est jean-clau qui était le nez
de
shermaise pendant 13 de plus en
plusieurs années et c'est on est dans ce
même univers quoi c'est à dire que dans
la dimension de la créativité il y a
quelque chose de très intime et puis il
y a toujours un cadre dans la créativité
on peut pas faire tout et n'importe quoi
c'est pas dire tiens je vais mettre ça
avec ça parce que ça va faire pouet
pouet ça va marcher c'est pas comme ça
c'est un petit peu comme un compositeur
en musique mais comment il réussit à
écrire moi j'ai l'impression que j'ai un
compositeur il a une partie du cerveau
que j'ai pas parce que je suis incapable
de mettre comme ça sur le papier des
notes de musique qui peuvent qui peuvent
apporter une mélodie mélodie symphonie
donc moi
je suis complètement totalement
admiratif mais si vous me dites je mets
un peu de curcuma un peu de coriandre un
peu de cumin une pointe de girofle et
peut-être un soupçon de cardamome je
sais exactement quel goût vous a pour
finir je ne sais ce comment ça se passe
les gens disent oui c'est un c'est pas
non c'est pas un talent
beaucoup de travail et surtout beaucoup
d'envie et puis le plaisir de goûter
alors vous avez pris du recul mais alors
du coup que vous faites l'inspecteur des
travaux finis ou vous êtes quand même
derrière votre fille derrière votre fils
et il y a encore la patronne parce que
quand on vous écoute on se dit c'est pas
possible il a pas pris ça retraite en
cuisine
avec ma femme j'en ai toujours à leur
côté mais c'est vraiment eux qui ont les
manettes je pense que je n'ai jamais
cuisiné avec mon site mon fils en dehors
de de on s'est jamais retrouvé face à
face sur un fourneau c'est pas bon la
cuisiner ensemble
on l'a fait simplement pour deux dîner
caritatifs
mais son quoi moi j'ai eu à la fois la
chance et la malchance de pas avoir de
pas être élevé par un père
mais jamais j'aurais voulu lui dire
tiens tu vois à ta place j'aurais fait
ça comme ça sauf que je trouve que je
suis pas à sa place lui c'est lui moi
c'est vrai et je vais laisser une totale
liberté
parfois je dis tiens j'aurais plutôt
fait avec ça comme ça je tiens il faut
que je lui dise le lendemain matin et je
passe la nuit dessus et je me dis mais
non ça sert à rien que je lui dise parce
que lui c'est son histoire il a raconte
de cette manière là et si même si
parfois je pense que c'est peut-être une
petite erreur moi j'en ai tellement fait
que conneries que il peut bien en faire
quelques unes donc c'est quoi une erreur
en cuisine parfois c'est une erreur
alors on peut considérationnaire parce
que moi me le plat mon plat préféré je
l'ai mis pendant deux jours sur la carte
et les gens l'ont détesté mais pour moi
ça reste toujours mon meilleur plat une
association melon de Porto de menthe et
de cardamome
de chacun ça c'est c'est la liberté de
chacun de pouvoir trouver si c'est bon
c'est pas mais
donc c'est peut-être une erreur c'est
peut-être une erreur de texture c'est
peut-être une c'est rare lui faire
rarement mais quelque chose qui va me
choquer et en fait c'est parfois
en l'occurrence là c'était pas la
cardamome en trop non non non pas du
tout peut-être peut-être pas assez
de cuisson de mélange
j'aurais peut-être un peu plus cuit ou
contraire
aller dans cette association où j'aurais
peut-être pas mis le parce que bien
souvent lorsque l'on cuisine
on ne déguste pas l'ensemble du plat et
lorsqu'on déguste le plat ça perçoit
parfois qui a il y a un décalage dans
les proportions mais c'est vraiment à la
marge et et et je
trouve qu'il a enfin bon
il est bluffant donc on est nous on est
derrière avec ma femme mais
on est on est bluffé donc on est avec
Mathilde elle qui était bon je rappelle
que Hugo était officiel et marine
marchande il a fait l'école du Havre il
y a l'âge de 24 ans il me dit mais je
lui dis mais tu es complètement cinglé
de voir à 24 ans commencé la cuisine et
il me dit bien avec ou sans toi et je
lui dis mais je lui dis mais pourquoi tu
gagnes très bien ta vie tu vas finir
comment dans
j'ai aussi une histoire à raconter et
quelques années plus tard notre fille
qui était avocate dans le droit des
affaires le droit de l'art vient nous
rejoindre mais alors là autant Hugo on a
dit là c'est compliqué parce que on sait
bien que dans tout univers se faire
annonce et compliqué mais se faire un
prénom c'est encore beaucoup plus dur
que les gens peuvent être une
cruauté redoutable et et Mathilde par
contre alors là on était aux anges parce
que elle c'est un avion de chasse qui
est arrivé c'est un soleil c'est une
énergie c'est c'est un rapport à l'autre
et qui est merveilleux et aujourd'hui
elle travaille dans la relation avec
1200 petits producteurs
recommence sa formation à 24 ans mais
moi j'avais une formation d'ingénieurs
chimiste
je vais me lancer dans la cuisine en
fait moi à l'époque oui
bon j'avais relaté tout à l'heure
j'étais victime de tentative de domicile
à l'âge de 21 ans je suis resté pendant
deux ans les yeux marqués sur un sur les
sur des sur des plafonds de clinique ou
d'hôpitaux je savais pas si un jour
j'allais pouvoir remarcher et je voulais
je savais que c'était une deuxième vie
que j'entamais j'ai voulu saluer la vie
j'étais à la recherche d'un moyen
d'expression de raconter le bonheur de
vivre au quotidien je t'ai pas peintre
j'étais pas musicien j'étais encore
moins littéraire un affreux petit
scientifique et j'ai trouvé que autour
de la table j'avais les copains de la
petite enfance qui était devenu
ostriculteur pêcheurs cultivateur il y
avait les copains et copines qui étaient
étudiants on prépare ces choses-là qui
ramenaient des bouteilles je dis mais le
goût de la vie c'est là dans la maison
et c'est là où j'ai cuisiné je jure
cuisiné dans cette maison c'était un Hob
by c'est plus c'est une passion que l'on
a transformé jamais on aurait pu
imaginer qu'on a on pensait que j'allais
faire ça à 4-5 ans dans tous les cas
pour exprimer le bonheur de vivre au
quotidien et rien de plus beau que la
cuisine mais pour chacun d'entre vous à
la maison c'est pour ça que j'invite
vraiment
chacun a retrouvé sa souveraineté
sa liberté ça souveraineté alimentaire
mais aussi un énorme plaisir que de
cuisiner surtout pas pensé
par exemple que pour dans le bien-être
il faut avoir une activité physique
aujourd'hui c'est un forme de plaisir
d'activité physique d'aller faire la
marge d'aller faire du jogging d'aller
faire que sais-je une activité
mais
se nourrir c'est tout d'un coup
retrouver l'usage de ses mains retrouver
le nez retrouvez le goût choisissant
d'un produit travailler il y en a pas le
temps mais de côté évidemment
il y a toujours le temps alors je pense
que la très grande majorité des
Françaises des français André je me
parle pas d'une catégorie de personnes
en particulier je pense à des jeunes
mamans qui vivent seuls et qui vivent
qui travaillent je sais pas loin de leur
lieu d'habitat très sincèrement je me
demande comment il réussit sa vie ces
personnes a raison mais en dehors de ces
personnes là la très grande majorité
nous avons évidemment tous le temps
c'est meilleur pour la planète
c'est meilleur pour son portefeuille
c'est meilleur pour sa santé c'est
meilleur pour son plaisir et c'est c'est
donner du c'est faire partager bien donc
c'est une cuisine fait du bien alors il
y a toujours les accords à Cormet et
alors on va parler de ce Muscadet que
vous nous avez apporté un vin évidemment
du Val de Loire c'est une AOC le
Bourgogne
couleur blanc évidemment un millésime
2020 c'est élevé sur liste donc c'est
une spécificité si ça dure
monsieur Landeron était un pionnier de
la biodynamie déjà des vins pratiquement
nature ça veut dire quoi
alors évidemment sans pesticides sans
entrant sans
ramasser à la main et puis évidemment
avec
un minimum de soufre et avec surtout des
levures indigènes et non pas exogènes
c'est un petit peu comme le pain la
farine vous allez chercher des levures
il y a à peu près trois levures
aujourd'hui dans le monde dans les vins
finalement 2020 une année sur l'autre
alors évidemment si vous mettez un
fongicide dans la vigne vous pouvez pas
avoir de levure donc comme il y a plus
de levure dans les vins on rajoute des
levures exogènes et donc on a des vins
d'une netteté avec une droiture et le
Muscadet qui a été tellement abîmé dans
son image où on a effectivement par
moment on a fait des vins c'est pas
toujours très bien très bien équilibré
surtout extrêmement acide et là on a des
on a voilà des seigneurs et aujourd'hui
il y a des beaucoup de jeunes dans tout
le dans tout le Val de Loire on va dire
d'ailleurs dans tout vignoble français
qui se sont réappropriés le vivant dans
la vigne qui ont renversé la table de
l'INAO
et le monde entier aujourd'hui s'arrache
ces vins en biodynamisme c'est vins
nature dans le monde de Copenhague à
Tokyo en passant par New York ou San
Francisco alors que il y a encore 15 ans
on disait les vins français ont été
laminés par ces vins du nouveau monde
mais c'est vain du Nouveau Monde sont
restés dans le 20e siècle avec d'abord
en irrigant on le fait pas en France
évidemment mais surtout en bourrant d'un
train d'engrais de pesticides en faisant
des vins des vins ce qu'on appelle des
vins conventionnelles mais ces vins là
c'est les vins qu'on faisait avant
guerre donc sur ce plateau on va voir si
vous êtes vraiment incollable à présent
c'est le quiz les quiz
Olivier Roellinger vous qui aimez deux
paix les saveurs les asperges avec vos
épices seriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations sur le niocman cette sauce
de poisson cette sauce qui relève les
plats vietnamiens sont vraies ou fausses
alors le Newman débarque en France en
1915 dans les rations militaires des
soldats vietnamiens engagés dans la
Grande Guerre vrai ou faux je pense que
je pense que c'est bien antérieur à tout
ça je pense que le peuple vietnamien a
utilisé le nuoc-mâm bien avant non mais
débarque en France à débarque en France
en 1915 dans les rations militaires des
soldats vietnamiens
alors là et moi je me suis pas je suis
passé fanberg
mais
je pense qu'il débarque en France à ce
moment là
peut-être oui oui
il y avait des Vietnamiens qui étaient
engagés dans l'armée française et on
leur a donné les Vietnamiens les
autorités vietnamien leur envoyer du New
yorkman pour les pour les doper un petit
peu c'est une source de protéines
extraordinaire les Vietnamiens compare
le rejet qu'inspire le gnoc-mâm aux
occidentaux au dégoût que leur procure
les escargots vrai ou faux
je pense que c'est faux parce que je
pense que les Vietnamiens mangent aussi
des escargots bravo c'est le dégoût que
leur procure les fromages parce que je
pense que le grand d'histoire à la fois
d'amour avec des drames avec le peuple
vétérinaire le peuple français le peuple
vietnamien ce sont des amoureux de la
table amoureux sont des gens qui vivent
pour manger et qui mangent pas pour
vivre à la différence de tous nos amis
anglo-saxons et je dois dire que et il
mange tout et il nous gaspille rien
c'est bourré de saveurs je dis toujours
la cuisine du Nord vietn c'est
probablement une des cuisines les plus
moderne au monde parce que c'est quand
même des gens qui ont vaincu les deux
grandes plus rares mais de l'époque
l'armée française et l'armée américaine
il fallait pas qu'il tombe malade donc
ils avaient une cuisine extrêmement
saine et tout était axé sur la santé de
la femme de la maman alors où la future
maman ou la maman qui attendait un bébé
et je trouve ça d'une extraordinaire
modernité absolument s'en gaspillage et
qui se marie si bien au champagne
exactement le mieux que m'amen tenait
une place de choix dans la cuisine de
Marguerite Duras vrai ou faux
je
la vois bien parce que c'est une femme
ouverte au monde extrêmement curieuse je
la vois bien aimer le bravo parce qu'en
plus vrai elle avait des racines elle
est née au Vietnam oui 1914 enfin le
Newman produit sur l'île de fou quoi que
au sud
bénéficie d'une AOP de l'Union
européenne vrai ou faux alors
bénéficie d'une AOP moi je connais bien
c'est alors je ne sais pas si c'est une
AOP de l'Union européenne dans tous les
cas elle bénéficie d'une appellation
sur cette île ou parce que il faut
surtout pas penser que le nope MAM c'est
du poisson pourri ce sont des poissons
frais mise en saumure c'est pour ça que
l'île de foucoq elle est très plate et
c'est il y a des salines et pour faire
du Noka il faut d'abord du sel une des
salines et ses petits poissons qui
ressemble un petit peu façon dans tous
les environs
non ça empêche pas
j'adore
pour répondre à votre question je pense
que oui c'est une vraie en 2013 en 2013
sur 4 sur 4 quasiment incollable sur le
vous êtes très fort très très fort on en
doutez pas alors vous savez qu'en France
le repas occupe une assez large place et
particulièrement en politique c'est
souvent là que ce nous les deals
politiques et que se fait la petite et
la grande histoire c'est la brève de
comptoir
alors Olivier Roellinger on vous a
demandé de réfléchir à éventuellement
une anecdote autour d'un repas en
politique vous avez sûrement dû
accueillir déjà des politiques dans
votre restaurant à l'époque mais je
crois que c'est pas forcément ce dont
vous vouliez nous parler alors tout
d'abord je considère que nos maisons
sont des maisons qui doivent garder une
confidentialité la plus totale j'en ai
eu évidemment des personnes illuses que
ce soit du monde politique ou d'autres
univers mais
avec c'est la règle dans la famille
rolinger on ne communique jamais sur
tout ce qui tous les personnes qui
viennent nous voir c'est la raison pour
laquelle il y a des gens illustres qui
viennent se cacher chez nous parce
qu'ils savent que c'est une règle d'or
ça c'est la première chose et je pense
que lorsqu'on est dans l'univers de
l'hospitalité on devrait toujours
conserver cette règle plutôt de faire le
buzz en disant il y a machin ou machine
qui est à la maison et balancer ça sur
les réseaux sociaux comme aujourd'hui
bref je ferme mon la parenthèse donc moi
je lui dis par contre vous parler de
politique et moi je vous parle politique
parce que
c'est avant tout politique c'est
politique parce que c'est au carrefour
des enjeux de nos sociétés en jeu
sociaux en jeu économique en jeu
culturel en jeu environnementaux mais
également en jeu de santé publique et
aujourd'hui je m'occupe beaucoup des
livres là je parie un collectif qui
s'appelle les pieds dans le plat et là
nous nous ont sorti un livre en
particulier avec germinal Perrot qui est
président du département de Dordogne
pour prouver que l'on peut faire dans
les cantines que ce soit les cantines
municipales gérée par les municipalités
évidemment les collèges gérés par les
départements et les lycées gérés par les
régions j'ai un petit peu la complexité
française mais que il faut arrêter de
demander à l'agro-industrie
de s'approprier l'alimentation de nos
enfants et que
on peut tout à fait faire une cuisine
maison 100% maison 100% locale et 100%
bio
pour pas trop cher pour quasiment le
même prix et avec en particulier des
effets induits nettement moins de que
d'aller dans l'agro-business et cette
chose là on l'a fait c'était le
programme politique de Germinal Perrault
moi j'invite quel que soit la couleur
politique des personnes de dire écoutez
moi mon programme
c'est que la cantine municipale
le collège et le lycée les enfants vont
être parfaitement noyés parfaitement
nourri c'est quoi c'est d'avoir
évidemment une cuisine parce que ça se
fait avec des cuisiniers des
diététiciens diététiciennes
c'est d'avoir des produits de saison des
produits locaux maximum et des produits
bio évidemment même si justement moi je
dis aux journées continuer à acheter du
bio
continuez à acheter du bio français il
faut sauver il faut sauver cette filière
ça a été complètement enfumé par ce
qu'on appelle la haute valeur
environnementale parce que ça c'est de
la poudre aux yeux il faut continuer à
s'engager dans le milieu
c'est de moins en plus vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui je le détiens d'un
grand producteur de yaourts dans la
région Bretagne aujourd'hui on va
jusqu'à acheter le produit le blé bio un
prix inférieur
au prix du lait conventionnel
pourquoi parce que il y a un contrat de
confiance qui s'est cassé à partir du
moment où les quatre centrales d'achat
se sont appropriés le bio le bio c'est
vrai que moi j'ai commencé en 1982
lorsqu'on allait sur le marché des Lices
à Rennes
on voyait trois gens un peu Baba
sûrement des fumeurs de pétards qui
arrivent avec deux trois carottes trois
navettes ils avaient raison petit à
petit avec aucun soude de de d'argent
public ils ont créé un contrat de
confiance avec les Françaises et les
Français et ce contrat est en train est
en train a été extrêmement abîmé lorsque
les grandes surfaces se sont dit ça
c'est un vrai label économique qui va
nous donner un levier pour faire des
marges beaucoup plus importantes que sur
des produits conventionnels et et
c'est à dire que comment on pouvait
avoir confiance
on sait très bien un producteur local
qui fait ses légumes bio et une centrale
d'achat qui achète du bio en France en
Europe et à l'autre bout du monde dans
des conditions
ça n'a plus de sens et ils ont
terriblement abîmé ce contrat de
confiance mais il faut le retrouver
allez retrouver vos producteur s bio
et mais par contre n'allez pas
nécessairement l'acheter en grande
surface merci pour le message votre
spécialité je le disais au début de
cette émission c'est le saint Pierre
autour des Indes car les épices sont
toujours fait le secret de votre cuisine
et c'est le dessous des plats
votre première boutique d'épices à
Cancale date de 1998 depuis la maison du
voyageur de votre dans votre ancien
restaurant accueille une cuisine
laboratoire où se fabrique le mélange
des épices et une boutique entrepôt le
tout dans une ambiance familiale puisque
votre fils est joint à l'aventure Emily
Sportello et Marion de vauchelle sont
allés à sa rencontre
je fais ce qu'on appelle une dégustation
là de trois variétés de poivre d'Inde on
a d'abord le panneau
une
il y a une puissance
et en même temps va arriver ce côté ce
côté bois côté un peu forêt poivre bâton
de cannelle ou encore baies rouges de
Madagascar le bureau déborde des piles
et d'odeurs on se croit dans un cabinet
de curiosité alors il y a il y a
beaucoup de choses sur cette table mais
j'ai avec mon père on a besoin de ce
petit capharnaüm pour pour être
concentré disponible à la dégustation
comme c'est comme si on avait un peu
tout notre orgue à parfum de matière
brute avec lesquelles on va pouvoir
faire des petits essais rapides avec
notre balance et voir un petit peu en
live bah tiens j'ai une inspiration je
la mets à l'épreuve est-ce que ça marche
en fait un atelier qui a pris place dans
la maison familiale qui accueillait à
l'époque le restaurant de Olivier
Roellinger la maison Bricourt les
personnes ressortaient d'un bon dîner
avec goûter une sauce retour des Indes
et on dit mais c'était extraordinaire
j'aimerais refaire la même chose à la
maison et donc on leur offrait des
petits sachets des petits flacons
d'épices que ma grand-mère remplissait à
la main et ma nounou écrivait les
étiquettes
ben voilà complètement manuscrite
aujourd'hui l'entreprise s'est
développée les épices se comptent par
centaines dans l'entrepôt et viennent
des quatre coins du monde elles sont
vendues mais surtout utilisées pour
créer des mélanges originaux au nom
évocateur comme poudre de Neptune ou
poudre de Vasco en référence au célèbre
navigateur portugais parce que
Saint-Malo était un port de la route
orientale des Indes qui commençait en
Inde qui passaient par Lorient et qui
finissait par Saint-Malo Saint-Malo a
fait sa richesse grâce aux épices grâce
à ses voyages assez nombreux voyage et à
l'époque on avait des petites armoiries
dans lequel il y avait des cases de
différentes tailles où on mettait ces
ivoires ses ordres etc etc et on a voulu
reproduire un peu cette image que vous
avez autour de vous avec des cases de
différentes tailles pour montrer que nos
ordres à nous ben c'était un peu nos
épices les clients sont séduits par
l'abondance mais surtout l'exotisme des
senteurs
c'est la petite touche supplémentaire
qui fait le tout prochain chantier
décarboné davantage encore le transport
des épices c'est le cas déjà du curcuma
de Guadeloupe qui voyage comme il y a
quatre siècles par bateau à voile
Olivier rollinger d'où viennent toutes
ces épices que qu'on trouve maintenant
dans vos boutiques est-ce que vous allez
sur place vous goûtez comment vous les
trouvez tout d'abord pourquoi des épices
à Cancale au départ dans la cuisine
c'était tout à l'heure c'était pour
raconter l'esprit d'aventure parce
qu'ici les gens là-bas sont nous sommes
paysan marins et aventuriers et cet
esprit réussir ses parties pour un pour
un petit malin ou un petit cancalé donc
comment je vais exprimer et là il y a on
m'avait raconté en 1981 quelqu'un qui
s'intéressait à l'histoire comme quoi
tout ce que l'on pouvait trouver dans
les murs de Saint-Malo les cotonnades
indiennes les soirées les porcelaine
c'est la dent tout ça mais à manger et
là il me raconte et on trouvait 14
épices certaines venaient de Chine
d'autres venaient d'Inde d'autres
venaient du Moyen-Orient d'autres
devenait déjà du Nouveau Monde c'est à
dire que la mondialisation des saveurs
était faite à Saint-Malo il y en avait
14 avec ses 14 j'ai fait mon premier
mélange le mélange retour des Indes
c'était West Indies eastindi c'était pas
un retour d'Inde bien évidemment et puis
j'ai compris que c'était bien l'histoire
je racontais l'histoire de mon pays
c'est la culture du pays de ce pays et
cette formidable aventure humaine que
d'aller à l'autre bout du monde avec des
bateaux qui souvent avancés plus de
l'arrière que de l'avant et avec en
connaissant pas la latitude puisque les
chronomètres fonctionnent pas enfin
était souvent défaillant donc comment
comment trouver la longitude plutôt
comment la calculer si on n'a pas un bon
cornemomètre donc c'est une formidable
aventure où il y a eu mal loin aussi
bien les caporniers que sur la route des
Indes et puis petit à petit lorsque moi
j'ai toujours mis en avant les
producteurs locaux que ce soit de la
terre ou de la mer et puis je me suis
dit il faut quand même aussi que je
rende un peu à ces hommes et ces femmes
qui sont souvent dans l'anonymat
et qui m'ont fait découvrir les épices
parce que lorsqu'on fermait trois mois
on reprenait les routes de ces messieurs
de Saint-Malo et là on a fait
connaissance avec ses petits producteurs
on a vous êtes allé sur place
de ne pas simplement acheter des épices
pour notre propre cuisine et d'aller
plus loin c'est à dire d'aider ces
communautés qui étaient un peu balayées
justement par un poivre indonésien et
autres comment on peut les aider en leur
achetant à un prix au-delà du prix du
commerce équitable d'ailleurs
c'était une formidable aventure avec les
ONG locales pour le collecter pour le
shipping pour le dédouanement donc
c'était une aventure humaine c'était des
rencontres mais comment vous avez fait
mais c'est 40 ans de vie c'est de
relation avec ces petits producteurs
j'avais été dans tous ces pays-là tous
ces pays-là
il y a plus de production il y a plus de
girofle
non il y a plus du tout par contre Sri
Lanka les cannelle et poivre ces
choses-là ou grenades ou le Mexique pour
les piments et les vanilles ou
Madagascar bien sûr on est allé une
fortune il y a quelques siècles
aujourd'hui ça vaut comme encore quelque
chose les épices on s'est battus pour
les épices aujourd'hui ça vaut plus rien
on a découvert le monde pour les
découvert le monde pour les et c'est une
poignée d'ailleurs ce petit peuple qui
est petit par la taille mais qui en 30
ans a découvert le monde en dehors de
l'Australie sont quand même faut rendre
hommage au portugais et mais à chaque
fois si vous voulez les épices c'est
surtout avec quelques massacres la clé
quand même mais évidemment voilà non
mais je voilà évidemment c'est il y a eu
des
mais enfin tout ce enfin malheureusement
malheureusement mais
peut-être excepté un sort de la touche
de la Ravardière qui était à Hugo au
cancalais qui lui donne des écrits
racontent comme quoi c'était quelqu'un
qui était qui protéger et qui était
soutenu par le indien mapoutch en
particulier parce qu'il devait fonder la
France et qui inoxyde voilà et
aujourd'hui on trouve son bus sans Luis
au Brésil bref non mais pour vous dire
que c'est les les épices c'est surtout
permettre de faire une cuisine
avec moins de graisse
moins de sel
et moins de sucre
et que tout le monde des épices le monde
végétal et permet de faire chanter
danser votre cuisine au quotidien
les épices sont à la cuisine
ce que la ponctuation est à la
littérature c'est d'ailleurs permet de
présenter comme le ponctuation permet de
présenter la phase 4 chez l'humour et
bien les épices permettent de présenter
la face cachée du meurt regardez comment
on peut faire tourner le boulet un grain
de riz dans une vinaigrette dans un
risotto dans un riz au lait c'est
toujours du riz mais un conseil
peut-être pour les gens qui nous
regardent quels sont les principales
épices qu'il faut qu'il faudrait avoir
chez soi pour supprimer les deux
excellents boives un poivre plutôt
viandard et plutôt un poivre légumes et
légumineuses et pâtes voilà ça c'est
deux choses parce que dans les poils où
les gens disent il y a le poivre noir le
poivre blanc et le poivre rouge poivre
vert mais en fait dans les poivres nous
je pense que j'étais le premier il y a
20 ans maintenant
à présenter des points les variétés
botaniques de poivre noir parce que tout
ça c'est la même plante réduire Malabar
comporte alors ça ce sont des lieux on
des territoires mais les variétés
botaniques c'est un karimunda du rackari
Mundi un pagno c'est comme nous on va
dire une boscope une rainette
d'Armorique dans les pommes et autres
donc et c'est toujours un point ça c'est
une première chose donc d'avoir deux
poivre et puis ensuite
j'ai envie de dire que tout de suite on
bascule tout de suite vers des mélanges
et moi c'est toute ma vie de faire des
mélanges parce que d'utiliser des épices
seul les gens m'en achètent parce que
moi je suis à la recherche des plus
belles aujourd'hui avec avec Mathilde
évidemment toute l'équipe mais
c'est un petit peu si vous allez chez un
parfumeur c'est un parfums je vais
prendre de bilan bilan un peu de vétiver
un peu de muscle un peu de géranium
et puis acheter des mélanges dans dans
une belle maison on va parler de la
viande cultivée maintenant laboratoire
parce qu'elle existe déjà à Singapour il
y a des startups qui travaillent aussi
en France alors est-ce que c'est
l'avenir en tout cas on en parle et on
met les pieds dans le plat
et Olivier avec une population qui ne
cesse de croître comment nourrir toute
la planète demain une course contre la
montre et lancée pour produire de la
viande de laboratoire s'il faudra encore
attendre chez nous pour la goûter un
poulet
issu de cellules souches et déjà
commercialisé dans les boucheries et
dans les restaurants à Singapour
reportage dans cette cité-État
Singapour est-elle en train de préparer
l'alimentation du futur
réponse dans cette boucherie haut de
gamme qui a pignon sur rue depuis 30 ans
elle est la première au monde à proposer
à ses clients de la viande pas comme les
autres
André Hubert vendait produit du monde
entier défilé de bœuf des côtes de porc
et le cuisses de volaille et désormais
de la viande cultivée en laboratoire ce
que nous avons de nouveau ce sont ces
brochettes de poulet de culture produite
localement
poulet de synthèse à 4 roues pièces
c'est de la viande fabriquée in vitro à
partir de cellules animales c'est du
poulet bien sûr c'est l'avenir de
cultiver du poulet sans avoir à tuer un
animal
ce poulet en brochette les Singapouriens
peuvent déjà le trouver dans leurs
assiettes préparation ici en cuisine
comme pour tout poulet à frire on le met
dans l'huile et dès que la peau est
dorée on le ressort
servi avec du taboulé plus cher que du
poulet conventionnel tous les jeudis
dans ce restaurant avant-gardiste c'est
au menu bonjour vous partagez je vous le
mets là
pour des raisons écologiques de
bien-être animal ou par curiosité ce
groupe d'amis tente l'expérience
le goût est bon
mais j'ai un peu l'impression de manger
un poulet qui vient d'aller à la gym
la viande est moins grasse
c'est un peu sec mais ça a le goût de
poulet
de la viande de synthèse poulet bœuf
crabe en beignets Singapour Paris sur
ses innovations alimentaires comment ça
marche démonstration dans cette start-up
spécialisée dans les produits de la mer
première étape des cellules de crustacés
sont prélevées et conservés dans du
nitrogène liquide à moins 180 degrés
. qui vont ensuite dans le centre de
production puis la production commence
dans ce laboratoire
aux cellules souches de crevettes on
ajoute des nutriments pour qu'elle
grandisse ensuite dans cette incubateur
la chair de la crevette se développera
alors dans ses fioles et non dans la
nature à ce stade expérimental cela
donne un kilo de crevettes à 70 euros
tout de même les crevettes dans la
nature mettent entre 6 et 8 mois à
grandir nous nous arrivons à avoir la
même quantité de chair de crevettes en
quatre à six semaines c'est la grande
différence si quelqu'un me demande si
notre méthode est plus durable consomme
moins d'énergie je lui réponds oui sur
ce seul argument le temps de production
est considérablement réduit
mélencheux principal pour la cité-État
c'est celui de l'indépendance
alimentaire 1% seulement du territoire
est occupé par l'agriculture résultat
pratiquement tous les produits de ce
marché par exemple sont importés c'est
pour cela que Singapour investit des
millions dans la recherche et commencent
à autoriser la vente de nourriture de
laboratoire mais l'idée de remplacer ces
crevettes élevées en milieu naturel par
des crevettes de synthèse n'a pas encore
fait son chemin je préfère manger du
vrai poisson c'est plus naturel un
aliment cultivant laboratoire c'est pas
pour moi moi je préfère la nourriture
plus traditionnelle le marché des
protéines alternatives est lancées et si
ça marche l'histoire retiendra que cette
révolution alimentaire a commencé à
Singapour
alors ce poulet il vous fait saliver ou
vous laborez déjà et vous détestez ce
monde de demain et ces assiettes qui
nous attendent il Maker il m'écœure
parce que c'est encore là d'abord
c'est se dire que c'est une poignée de
personnes qui vont s'approprier encore
un peu plus l'alimentation du monde et
en particulier tout le monde des
protéines et ce sont les gafas
c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui tous ces tous
ces géants du numérique en Californie
qui veulent s'approprier de gauche
je peux être partout moi vous savez moi
ce que j'aime parce que j'aime c'est
cette droite dans mes bottes et sincère
et dans le bon sens et pas se voiler la
face c'est pas donc les premières choses
c'est est-ce que l'on souhaite laisser
entre les mains de quelques-uns
l'ensemble des protéines du monde
première chose s'approprie donc de
l'histoire de l'énergie seulement faux
parce que ce sont des usines il se
trouve que moi je je parraine
les travaux de la fondation de
l'Académie de médecine française et j'ai
eu l'occasion de rencontrer des gens
absolument merveilleux et avec un livre
blanc qui vous sort le premier juin à
destination en particulier de tous les
députés ah pour qu'ils comprennent il
est conclusions de ce livre blanc c'est
que l'alimentation la bonne alimentation
saine pour le corps pour la santé elle
vient rejoindre l'alimentation qui est
bonne pour la planète là c'est dangereux
pour la santé et alors là c'est
dangereux pour la santé pourquoi parce
que si je me permets d'abord l'énergie
ce sont des normes usines qui se doivent
être totalement aseptisé
comme une usine pharmaceutique donc au
niveau de l'énergie c'est absolument
énorme d'autre part utilisent énormément
de plastique et en particulier beaucoup
de perturbateurs endocriniens que l'on
trouve dans ces aliments pour conserver
les aliments pour conserver pour les
séparer parce que comment ça fonctionne
nous avons des bio-réacteurs espèce de
bouillon de culture de bactéries on a
effectivement ces cellules souches pour
qu'elles deviennent des cellules
musculaires on va y associer des
hormones de croissance des hormones de
croissance le dit pas dans les
croissance c'est interdit en Europe ne
croisent on a interdit les injections du
hormone de croissance qu'il faut dire
elle est pas autorisée en Europe
aujourd'hui
parce que on sait jamais dans l'avenir
ça pourrait être autorisé
un pays qui jusqu'au bout doit dire non
c'est quand même la France le pays des
Droits c'est aussi le droit ça veut dire
non à ce marché mais je trouve que c'est
un fonds
pour que des gens s'approprient
l'alimentation du monde pour que deux
le gain au niveau de l'énergie des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ça
c'est totalement bullshit c'est
totalement faux de retrouver notre
souveraineté alimentaire parce qu'on
parle comme ça aujourd'hui il faudrait
on importe énormément par exemple de
viande la moitié de nos poulets
en Bretagne quand même bien placé pour
savoir que on exporte une grande partie
de nos poulets en particulier dans les
émirats et que nous il nous reste les
fientes pour nous les bretonnes et les
Bretons donc dans les cantines la moitié
des poulets viennent de l'étranger dans
les cantines je le tiens d'un
responsable de l'achat d'une grande
centrale d'achat française pour tout le
grand ouest qui m'a expliqué que les
poulets aujourd'hui de batterie à 43
jours bas de gamme ne sont plus
référencés dans les centrales d'achat
ils partent ou à l'export en particulier
pour les Emirats parfois pour les
nourrir les travailleurs dans les
émirats sans commentaire et deuxièmement
il parle dans le cantine de France c'est
à dire qu'on donne les plus vilaines
volailles il faut donc on peut alors si
vous voulez les gens qui aujourd'hui qui
sont souvent d'ailleurs les fils et les
petits-fils de ceux qui investissaient
dans les abattoirs de Chicago
aujourd'hui ils sont en Californie ils
expliquent qu'ils vont nous faire
d'une viande
ils vont s'approprier totalement cette
chose là c'est c'est absolument pas
recevable parce que parallèlement il
lance le mouvement vegan sont les mêmes
alors que le bon sens en France c'est de
retrouver le bon sens d'avoir des
élevages de qualité en France parce que
l'élevage les animaux on en a besoin
dans les prairies on en a besoin pour la
biodiversité ça fait partie d'un
équilibre ce qu'il y a d'inacceptable
effectivement c'est la souffrance
animale c'est ces élevages qui sont plus
des élevages mais des usines à protéines
et c'est ça le scandale c'est le produit
de souffrance animale si on fait de la
viande à partir
mais depuis la nuit des temps l'élevage
on l'a fait mais ce mouvement de dire la
souffrance animale de tuer un animal
mais manger c'est tué oui évidemment
c'est une salle une salade elle pleure
je coupe une salade elle pleure elle a
une larme blanche aussi
on coupe la vie pour se nourrir mais ça
c'est le cycle et le rap l'idée de dire
je ne veux plus tuer un animal pour me
nourrir ça c'est une civilisation qui
est restée totalement adolescente qui
refuse la mort d'ailleurs on ne voit
plus un corbillard passé lorsque vous
avez eu les tours Center n'avait pas vu
un cadavre américain non plus haut
jamais quand vous dites ça non ça veut
dire que on refuse on refuse la mort si
on est dans le génisme et on considère
que la mort ne fait plus partie de leur
vie alors qu'elle fait tellement partie
de la vie donc il faut il faut et donc
finalement la seule cadavre que l'on
voit c'est le rôti au milieu de la table
quand on amène le rôti de porc ou le
rosbif donc ça n'a effectivement c'est
très facile de dire ça mais moi je
reviens la viande de qualité et des
éleveurs qui sont absolument respectueux
des animaux même si effectivement afin
des animaux doivent être tués pour se
nourrir mais c'est
absolument insupportable de jouer sur
cette corde en disant il faut il faut
passer par les Gafa par les Californie
par ces gens qui vont nous faire mais
ces trucs c'est c'est absolument
abominable et au niveau de la santé
c'est absolument cette viande là
totalement dépourvu de vitamines B12 on
a compris
c'est non on va passer à présent au
dessert et c'est le péché mignon
avec une tarte à la rhubarbe et soyons
clairs ce n'est pas un dessert breton
mais il n’est pas très loin de l'autre
côté de la Manche et oui cette tarte
cartonne au Royaume-Uni ou la rhubarbe
là-bas cette plante à outils jacides et
préparer depuis le 18e siècle 18e siècle
pardon tarte aussi traditionnelle aux
États-Unis et c'est un totem de la
cuisine de la Nouvelle Angleterre c'est
bien ça ce chômage en a parlé des uns de
la route des Indes là il y a la route
parce que pour la rue justement ma femme
est InCar anglaise et puis moi les
Anglais je je sont des
il me passionne les anglais parce que je
crois que la culture anglaise mais je
crois qu'il nous le rendent bien on a
l'impression parfois on les on les il
nous émerveille pour les mêmes raisons
que parfois on peut les on peut aller
c'est à dire que c'est si on fait les
détester et on peut totalement les les
adorer parce que jamais les enfants
non je crois pas non je crois pas je
crois que peu près le même rapport ça
peut même rapport
ils adorent les Français les Français
ils adorent notre culture ils adorent
notre cuisine et moi j'ai voulu rendre
là parce que c'est une saveur à la fois
basée assidulé et ben c'est le goûts de
l'Angleterre c'est ce goût de bonbons
anglais c'est cette acidité de la vie et
qui est évidemment qui qui est
l'expression même du printemps
on veut faire absolument des tartes aux
fraises alors qu'il faut attendre encore
un petit peu pour avoir de bonnes
fraises mais profitons de la rhubarbe
profitons de la rhubarbe alors
profitez-en vous allez la goûter pendant
ce temps-là on écoute la musique que
vous
choisissez
et surtout au Finistériens
donc j'ai choisi
alors hommage à la effectivement à la
culture bretonne là aussi bah oui parce
que je crois que moi je suis un
indépendantiste breton enfin je l'ai été
pendant très longtemps quand j'étais
adolescent et je crois toujours à
l'identité culturelle bretonne qui doit
être
qui doit être présenté je dis toujours
avoir une identité c'est pas se couper
des autres je crois qu'au contraire
c'est une
identité c'est justement la possibilité
de pouvoir partager une partie de son
identité avec l'autre et d'ailleurs
s'enrichir de l'identité de l'autre pour
pour faire pour développer la sienne et
il a et là Didier ce qui banque est
devant la mer et qui avec son piano
[Musique]
et merveilleux merci de nous avoir
offert en tout cas ce moment d'avoir
partagé déjeuner avec nous Olivier
rolandinger
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro de politique à table
sur LCP
[Musique]